und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend wenn lichter kameras und
live-übertragungen maßstab für
politische bedeutung sind dann hat die
junge union ihren deutschlandtag perfekt
terminiert als erste große
parteiveranstaltung nach der wahl es gab
halt nur anders als geplant keinen sieg
zu feiern und während die veranstaltung
lief schob die harmonie schau von spd
fdp grünen die union gestern noch tiefer
ins abseits jahre in der opposition sind
ihr schon so gut wie sicher solche
niederlagen haben anders als das
sprichwort es sagt auch viele väter und
einer hat sich heute noch mal dazu
bekannt armin laschet und er hat dabei
keine halben sachen gemacht mathis
feldhoff berichtet
armin laschet kommt um buße zu tun eine
geste ein auftritt die manchen
jungpolitiker heute in dieser klarheit
offenbar überrascht hat gestern noch war
hart kritisiert worden heute nimmt er
mit seiner offenheit der kritik den wind
aus den segeln
die verantwortung für dieses ergebnis
die trage ich als vorsitzender und als
kanzlerkandidat den wahlkampf die
kampagne habe ich zu verantworten und
sonst niemand dass in der anschließenden
debatte soll team die eu genau dafür
respekt und legt auch den finger in die
wunde
jetzt aber haben sie gezeigt ich finde
das kurz ehrlichkeit dazu das zu sagen
aber jetzt chapeau für diese ehrlichkeit
denn immer ehrlich sind deutschland mag
niemand den sich streitet das haben wir
2015 er auch zwischen seehofer und
merkel gesehen laschet stellt sich der
debatte auch weil er sagt meint sie die
eu vorsitzender muss zu seiner jungen
union kommen das sieht der andere
vorsitzende ganz anders markus söder hat
er erst zu und dann abgesagt sodass
scheint der diskussion auch über ihnen
lieber aus dem weg zu gehen
und monitoring weil ich hier bei den
bayern bilder wirkt genervt letzte woche
hatte schon die bayerische junge union
ihn hart kritisiert die zäsur leitfigur
bekommt schrammen
laschet erwähnt so dass namen nicht und
gibt ihm doch nein mit wenn man vor ort
entschieden hat die oder der ist unser
kandidat und danach sagen die anderen
die nicht gewählt worden sind ja aber
wir hatten trotzdem den besseren wenn
man so in wahlen geht gewinnt man nicht
den frust der jungen union bekommen die
generalsekretäre zu hören mit beispielen
aus der beliebten informationsplattform
wahlomat
ökologische landwirtschaft soll stärker
gefördert werden als convista
landwirtschaft die union keine position
der gesetzliche mindestlohn soll im jahr
2022 erhöht junior position die
karosserie das ist nur der anfang eine
ungemütliche stunde für den ehemaligen
vorsitzenden und jetzt generalsekretär
die parteiführung habe fehler gemacht in
diesem wahlkampf sowohl die cdu als auch
bei csu und das musste er auch deutlich
gesagt werden scherbengericht und
schaulaufen wird deutschland tage sind
oft beides beim heutigen schaulaufen
zeigten sich mögliche kandidaten für den
cdu vorsitz auch wenn sie noch verdeckt
agiere
es ist jetzt mal die generationen nach
merkel
die jetzt mal in verantwortung muss
es sind bekannte gesichter und weniger
bekannte welche die schon mal kandidiert
haben und welche den plötzlich die
herzen zufliegen
ich will dass in zukunft nicht das
kanzleramt entscheidet sondern die
partei bei uns müssen die debatten
stattfinden kann
die itu erfüllt an diesem wochenende mal
wieder ihre aufgabe sei es so graf zu
sein für die stimmung in der auch wenn
richtung und führung noch nicht klarer
sind als zuvor
apropos stimmung als vor 16 jahren
angela merkel ihr amt antrat da war da
draußen einer schon da und damals schon
schwierig laptop erdogan damals premier
heute herrscher der türkei er wird
länger bleiben als sie heute ein
abschiedsbesuch der noch einmal zeigte
in welcher zwickmühle eine
regierungschefin steckt die auch mit
unangenehmsten partnern zurechtkommen
muss da waren immer wieder haltung und
balance gefragt und schwer in einklang
zu bringen wie das heute ausgehen
berichtete pott aus istanbul
zum abschied gab es für die kanzlerin
noch einmal postkarten idylle am
bosporus mit perfektem sonnenschein
begeisterten autofahrern und type
erdogan als reiseführer der jetzt wo in
berlin ein machtwechsel an steht lobende
worte fand für so wörtlich seine
freundin merkel
es gibt für die türkei viele
schwierigkeiten auf dem weg zur
eu-mitgliedschaft trotzdem hat sich frau
merkel stets für uns eingesetzt dafür
danken wir ihr wir werden das in guter
erinnerung reifen
zehn mal reiste sie in die türkei ein
vergnügen war es selten eher eine
politische achterbahnfahrt aus der
andere längst ausgestiegen wären merkel
blieb aus einsicht in die notwendigkeit
wir merken dass wir geostrategisch eben
sehr voneinander abhängen ob wir gleich
agieren oder nicht das wird jetzt mit
der frage der taliban eine rolle spielen
das spielt mit der frage der flüchtlinge
eine rolle
2010 gab es eine friedenstaube da wo der
erdogan noch als reformer geschätzt das
änderte sich schnell erdogan baute seine
macht aus und den rechtsstaat ab der ton
wurde rauer dann reise ich bis hin zum
afro frau merkel sie unterstützen nazi
methoden gegenüber meinen türkischen
mitbürgern in deutschland ein tiefpunkt
merkel kam trotzdem wieder viel zu sagen
hatte man sich dann nicht mehr aber
merkel braucht erdogan zu unterstützung
für den flüchtlings packt daran hat sich
bis heute nichts geändert
außergewöhnlich ist im blick auf
syrische flüchtlinge und wir haben uns
natürlich auch über das thema
afghanistan unterhalten damit menschen
aus afghanistan nicht auch opfer von
schleppern und schleusern werden müssen
wir sicherstellen dass humanitäre hilfe
in afghanistan geleistet wird erdogan
weiß um seine schlüsselposition in der
flüchtlingsfrage und er weiß um die
macht der bilder eine aufgeräumte
kanzlerin lächelnd bei ihm zu gast das
macht sich gut in der heimischen presse
über die vielen deutschen staatsbürger
die unter fadenscheinigen terror
vorwürfen in der türkei inhaftiert sind
wird doch nicht berichtet merkel spricht
von kontroversen einer menge
schwierigkeiten die noch nicht
ausgeräumt sein energische vorhaltungen
sind das nicht wir haben natürlich
manchmal auch sehr unterschiedliche
betrachtungen
an der terrorismus vorwurf gilt und wann
er nicht gilt das könne man so merkel
nur im gegenseitigen gespräch lösen oder
auch nicht
manches dauert sehr lange dafür haben 16
jahren nicht ausgereicht aber manches
ist auch gelungen auf dem weg dazwischen
er hoffe auf weitere gute zusammenarbeit
auch mit der nächsten regierung in
berlin betonte erdogan es klang ein
wenig wehmut mit so gut wie mit merkel
das schwant dem türkischen präsidenten
wird es vielleicht nicht mehr werden
und nachrichten von gundula gause bei
den tödlichen angriff auf den britischen
tory abgeordneten david eines geht die
polizei hinweisen auf einen
islamistischen hintergrund nach bei dem
festgenommenen tatverdächtigen soll es
sich um einen briten somalischer
herkunft handeln der fall hat in ganz
großbritannien betroffenheit ausgelöst
jimmie johnson und oppositionschef
stammer legten am tatort kränze nieder
helmes war gestern während einer
bürgersprechstunde erstochen worden
zehntausende menschen haben in rom gegen
faschismus demonstriert gewerkschafts
anhänger und linke gruppen forderten
dabei auch die auflösung der
rechtsextremen partei hannover einige
ihrer mitglieder hatten bei einer demo
gegen korona regeln vor einer woche ein
gewerkschafts gebäude in rom angegriffen
in russland sind binnen eines tages mehr
als 1000 menschen mit oder ancona
gestorben so viele wie noch nie in der
pandemie auch die zahl der
neuinfektionen ist mit 33.200 binnen 24
stunden auf höchststand hauptgrund ist
laut russischen behörden die geringe
impfbereitschaft nur 32 prozent der
russen sind vollständig geimpft
der heutige welternährungstag soll daran
erinnern dass weltweit menschen hungern
im vergangenen jahr stieg die zahl auf
mehr als 800 millionen wegen kriegen der
pandemie und folgen der klimakrise auch
in kenia sind wegen der anhaltenden
dürre insbesondere kinder massiv unter
ernährt zu helfen ist ihnen mit spenden
an das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf hunger in afrika weitere
informationen auf spenden zdf de und im
zf text
im nachhinein betrachtet ist die
digitale revolution also die totale
information über alles für alle überall
mit einem fatalen fehler gestartet sie
hat vorgegaukelt dass zuverlässiges
wissen und fakten umsonst zu bekommen
wären das hat die welt der
informationsmedien an den rand des
zusammenbruchs getrieben und dort stehen
viele immer noch nun und das wird ein
riesen thema auf der frankfurter
buchmesse fürchten autoren und
buchverlage dasselbe für ihre branche
wenn nämlich die schöne alte welt der
öffentlichen bibliotheken die bücher
fast umsonst ausleihen digital wird und
nicht mehr vier fünf exemplare kostenlos
im regal stehen sondern viele vielmehr
für immer weniger geld isabel de la vega
über neue angst um ihre lebensgrundlage
das buch
schreiben davon leben autoren wie juli
zeh sie fühlen sich nun in ihrer
wirtschaftlichen existenz bedroht kurz
vor dem start der buchmesse haben fast
200 autoren eine kampagne gestartet
gegen eine geplante neuregelung der
ausleihe von ebooks schreiben sei nicht
umsonst
wir versuchen zu verhindern dass auf dem
buchmarkt was ähnliches passiert wie auf
dem musikmarkt nämlich dadurch durch
dass die nutzer sich daran gewöhnen
kulturelle produkte kostenlos aus dem
internet runterzuladen am ende für die
urheber und urheberin nichts mehr
übrigbleibt worauf sie ihre existenz
stützen können die öffentlichen
bibliotheken bieten ihren mitgliedern
ebooks über das portal online an die
onleihe boomt weil die verlage dabei
aber nicht so viel verdienen wie ein
verkauften e-books oder gedruckten
büchern halten sie zumindest ihre
bestseller für die onleihe für mehrere
monate zurück das wollen die
bibliotheken ändern denn bücher seien
ein kulturgut auf dass die
öffentlichkeit ein recht habe wir
fordern eine gesetzliche regelung für
den fall für den verleih für ebooks dass
die verlage verpflichtet werden mit
erscheinen eines ebooks den bibliotheken
dieses e-book anzubieten
der bundesrat hat eine entsprechende
gesetzesinitiative
vorgelegt die die verleger verpflichten
soll den bibliotheken ihre werke sofort
nach dem erscheinen auch für die online
zur verfügung zu stellen das aber wäre
ein angriff auf das besonders lukrative
geschäft mit den neuerscheinungen wir
betrachten das mittlerweile ist eine
substanzielle gefahr die zahlen haben
uns alle überrascht die entwicklung hat
uns alle überrascht und deswegen gibt es
jetzt diese initiative verlesen die
darauf aufmerksam macht dass die online
bereits eine größenordnung eine
dimension erreicht hat die für uns
bedrohlich ist der bibliotheksverband
beschwichtigt sicher es kann zu einem
gewissen kleinen umsatzrückgang führen
aus unserer sicht jedenfalls aber dass
das jetzt sozusagen zum zusammenbruch
des gesamten verlagswesens führt das
finde ich deutlich übertrieben
also ein ebook was in der online laie
über eine bibliothek ausgeliehen wird
bringt mehr oder weniger für den autors
7 cent pro nutzung wenn man sich das
vorstellt und dann versucht auszurechnen
wie viele ausleihen der jetzt braucht um
jeden monat seine miete zu bezahlen dann
merkt man sofort dass das einfach nicht
gehen kann der streit um die digitale
ausleihe wird auch auf der buchmesse ein
großes thema sein
china hat drei taikonauten ins all
geschickt zur bislang längsten bemannten
raumfahrt mission in der geschichte des
landes nach gut sechs stunden flug
dockte sie an der halbfertigen
raumstation tiangong zu deutsch
himmelspalast an die zwei männer und
eine frau werden sie nun ein halbes jahr
lang weiter aufbauen die gewinnzahlen
vom lotto ohne gewähr 7 20 21 27 29
34 superzahl 6 weitere gewinnzahlen auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf seite
55 6 das herbstwetter bleibt wechselhaft
die sonne kommt aber immer mal durch
morgen gibt es im norden dichte wolken
und an den küsten etwas regen sonst
teils sonnig teils zäher nebel oder
hochnebel bei 11 bis 16 grad am montag
im norden am dienstag im westen regen
sonst bei 12 bis 20 grad neben sonne
auch wolken oder nebel am mittwoch
stürmisch wechselhaft und bis zu 22 grad
warum
eines noch still und leise ist eine
epoche zu ende gegangen gerd ruge ist
tot der letzte der pionier generation
großer korrespondenten die nach dem
krieg in eine welt hinausgezogen sind
die damals noch voller rätsel weit und
groß war er hat sie uns nahe gebracht
und immer ging es ihm dabei um die
menschen die er dort traf in russland in
china in amerika und den tausend anderen
damals für fast alle seiner zuschauer
unerreichbaren ecken und mancher und
manchem hat er damals flausen in den
kopf gesetzt dass eines tages doch mal
so ähnlich zu versuchen wie er und er
selbst blieb unerreicht und wenn du es
wirklich einen jenseits gibt dann würde
alles dran setzen uns berichtet zu
schicken bleiben wir mal besser
empfangen
alles vom sport jetzt im sportstudio mit
dunja hayali bis morgen
[Musik]